let's get into audience questions for
the week first one hey David Thomas
Jefferson suggested rewriting the
Constitution every 20 years would this
have been a good idea I completely agree
with the concept that the Constitution
needs to be updated and that
increasingly there are many elements of
it that just do not reflect the
realities of modern society I am NOT a
constitutional originalist I've made
that very very clear I think that it
would be much better if there was a
mechanism through which the Constitution
could be updated beyond just an
amendment to the Constitution we've of
course spoken about that to reflect the
realities of living in 2018 rather than
in the late 18th century for example I
think a full rewriting of the
Constitution every 20 years in modern
political circumstances would be an
unmitigated and unfettered disaster
specifically because once you start to
consider who is it that would do the
rewriting and who is in power at the
time that it would be rewritten if you
think the census gets political with
everything that right rides on the
census given that it takes place every
10 years and whoever's in power the year
after that has a big say in how
districts are redrawn in a lot of the
country just imagine what you would have
if whoever's in power has significant
influence over the every 20 year
rewriting of the Constitution so I
absolutely think we need a mechanism to
make the Constitution current and
relevant and I think it's increasingly
out-of-date and irrelevant but rewriting
the thing every 20 years is very very
dangerous yeah I'd be very worried that
our individual rights wouldn't be
protected like free speech and freedom
of the press and all these things that
we hold so dearly to ourselves and also
do you know even just going article by
article are we gonna delegate the powers
differently or is Congress going to be
in charge of one thing now and the
Supreme Court in charge of another thing
and the president and in charge of
another thing is all that going to shift
around every 20 years well we can't do
that but it sounds like you're saying
you're against the rewriting of it at
all yeah no I I think we just need to
strengthen the amendment process and
make it easier because you know we
haven't seen in the 28th amendment yet
hasn't been an amendment to the
Constitution in like 40 years right and
part of that is because it's just so
hard to do we have to go through the
Congress you have to go through States
and it's just hard to get that
bipartisan support now
so if I understand correctly you you're
into fixing the shortcomings of the
Constitution as originally written based
on modern society not by changing what
was written but by making amendments
that either clarify expand or change
particular parts of the Constitution
rather than rewriting I think 80% of it
o is okay we were right to get rid of
parts of it certainly that you know
black people are three-fifths of a
person right that had to go abolition of
alcohol that had to go but I think there
are a process he's laid out in the
Constitution that will allow us to get
to where we want as a society and we can
do it all within what we have right now
it's very tough because once you put a
timeline on it like even any mass
overhaul every 20 years a lot of times
you've got the same you have court cases
that can drag on for six years things
could change dramatically when there's a
rewriting that would fundamentally
change the underpinnings of a particular
court case that might be on year five or
some time there's just that's not a
defense of not updating the Constitution
but the the idea of a full rewriting
every twenty years seems very
problematic I agree that we need a
better and more effective system to
really be able to make changes that that
are important there's the idea of saying
that you consider so right now Supreme
Court Court precedent from the Supreme
Court can be considered in conjuction
conjunction or clarifying with regard to
elements of the Constitution like
Antonin Scalia has talked about the
Second Amendment is not absolute in
every way right but it's still not
considered a modifier of the
Constitution there's the idea that maybe
Supreme Court decisions can actually
become part of a sort of de facto bill
of rights or modifications to the
Constitution that's very dangerous
because it's political appointees that
are on the Supreme Court so I'd be
scared about that as well so I don't
actually know to answer the question the
right way to set this up but a full
rewriting every 20 years for me it's not
the way for yeah like if it happened
right now imagine who'd be on that
committee Mike Pence disasters Kobach
Ben Carson we don't want that you could
end up with Ted Nugent rewriting the
Constitution of the United States if
it's up to trump so incredibly dangerous
and of course you could say well we we
would we would outline how the rewriters
are selected
but that could also be changed right so
that that's we got to think about that
but I think the idea that the
Constitution becomes outdated over time
is very very true